Avete presente l'estate scorsa che
faceva un caldo bestia acquista anche tu
Favi ventilatore il faviventilatore è
dotato dell'ultima tecnologia
all'avanguardia per la climatizzazione
dell'aria non sporca non fa troppo
rumore e funzionabile tu sai dove vanno
inserite
quest'estate è peggio Ho provato a
sdraiarmi per terra ma o il parquet e fa
ancora più caldo
ho anche provato a schiavizzare degli
amici non ha funzionato come speravo più
forte Ho provato anche a rovesciarmi un
miliardo di Polaretti in faccia e così
la situazione è leggermente migliorata
devo dire solo che la situazione era
leggermente scomoda sei anche tu sei
stanco di tutto questo caldo Fai come me
l'anno scorso via un sms con scritto
Cristo che caldo al 333 666990 e
ricevilo a casa oggi stesso attenzione
mi Favi il ventilatore potrebbe avere
effetti indesiderati quasi puliti e
vomito non somministrare ai bambini via
inferiore 85